les requins pèlerins profite du soleil
du large dans le golfe du saint laurent
l'animal de dix mètres se caractérise
notamment par une bouche de grande
taille son apparence imposante a de quoi
faire peur ça make up un petit peu pour
ceux qui font du sport et du kayak la
planche
c'est pas trop sécurisé à je passe comme
si ces carnivores
ça mange du poisson et de la viande qui
nous on est gagnant d' de nombreux
citoyens ont alerté le centre de
recherche et l'éducation de sept-îles à
la suite de leurs observations
mais la menace n'est toutefois pas
fondées selon année goualo il ya aucun
danger les requins pèlerins ce sont des
requins qui sont inoffensifs pour les
humains donc ils vont filtrer l'eau et
donc l'eau va passer à travers les
branchies et ça va faire un espèce de
filtres un peu comme les baleines
justement vont filtrer l'eau et ils vont
se nourrit de plancton donc de petits de
petits organismes microscopiques
donc il n'y a aucun danger pour les
humains cette saison au moins six serait
qu'un pèlerin ont été observées dans la
région de sept-îles c'est plus qu'à
l'habitude
la température plus élevée de l'eau
pourrait expliquer leur présence
l'animal aime bien se prélasser près de
la surface pour se réchauffer au soleil
la météo clémente combinée à la faible
quantité de précipitations reçues ont pu
contribuer à garder le dessus de l'eau
plus chaud ces lois surface qui est
chaude après 1,2 m
c'est qu'il ya pas de brassage n'ai pas
beaucoup de hauts beaucoup de bas il n'y
a pas beaucoup de gras vins donc lourd
est comme stjarnan sur le dessus de
l'eau chaude reste année en dessous
dessus mais la chaleur on ne fait pas
plaisir courquin les baigneurs eux aussi
profitent de ce milieu d'été parmi les
plus chauds jamais enregistrés dans
l'est du québec
et si cathy larouche radio canada
sept-îles